[Music]
hey everybody new Punisher let's freak
out about this and we got confirmation
on when the infinity war trailer is
going to drop so I know you want to talk
about that first I'll explain that real
quick then I'll talk about the Punisher
because they also teased all kinds of
battle band stuff too so just make sure
you subscribe to get everything and in
the name of awesome things there is a
new round of that Thor ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so the deal with the infinity war is
that a couple separate people from
inside Marvel both actors and official
corporate people confirm that there's
going to be a trailer on the 29th of
September so what is so special about
that day it seems so arbitrary Thor
isn't dropping till November and it
would make sense that they drop a teaser
a couple days before Thor comes out but
why dropped something at the end of
September 29th other than they just feel
like being super awesome to us well it's
actually the premiere of Marvel's
Inhumans so it sounds like they're gonna
drop the trailer during the first
episode of Inhumans Inhumans is a Friday
show so it's premiering and it'll air
each week on Friday nights they probably
just want to juice up the ratings for
that first episode so how better to do
that then get the world to wait for
their infinity war trailer through that
episode so you don't know anything about
where that episode is dropping it's ABC
Friday night and I believe it's 8:00
p.m. Eastern Time so sometime during the
first two episodes that they drop I
think they're dropping the first two
episodes it's not just one episode
sometime during that the infinity war
trailer will drop then I'll do my video
for it we can freak out I'm expecting a
more polished version of what we got at
Comic Con although it won't be the exact
same footage it'll be a little shorter
than that maybe a minute long teaser but
we can talk about that if we get more
information before then but I just love
the idea that Marvel's official Twitter
is just like oh hell yeah infinity war
trailer September 29th be ready but you
probably heard all the crazy news about
Punisher they're doing the battle van
this is actually what it looks like we
haven't seen the inside of it so
presumably it'll be a little pared down
because this is his first season he'll
get way more [ __ ] as he goes into season
2 they play these Netflix series a
little more on the ground so I'm not
expecting it to be quite as crazy as it
is in the comics with exception to the
brutality so that's what I've really
seen people talking about the last
couple of weeks in the news is how crazy
the Punisher is going to get with the
violence I don't know how I'm gonna make
videos for it because YouTube has been
so weird with the way is censors content
because logically what you would do is
instead of a standard Easter Egg video
you would do Punishers best kills for
each episode because he kills so many
people just like this real badass take
down to the next one to the even crazier
one at the end of the episode but
what'll probably happen is is I'll try
to do a video about that and then if
YouTube likes tries to slap me in the
face and censor my video then I'll just
have to adjust based on that so be
prepared but I'm usually pretty good
with the way I step around problems like
that like if they haven't censored my
Game of Thrones videos before and I do
like the WTF moments then I'm not
expecting it to be too different for
Punisher but we'll have a good laugh
watching me try to do Punisher videos
with all the blood and gore without you
two trying to super ban me but there's
another daredevil character they
confirmed the Turk he crossed over to
Luke Cage - he got his ass kicked by
daredevil two seasons in a row then he
got his ass kicked on Luke Cage so you
guessed it he buys and sells weapons
that's kind of like the Punishers bread
and butter so of course he's probably
going to get the drop on him during a
weapons deal and just lay into him so
the Turk is like the new punching bag
that just goes around the different
Netflix series he's like the whipping
boy when you want to laugh watching
someone get their ass kicked by the
Punisher you burning in the Turk
because we both know I'll be back out by
the enemy
but as for this other footage they're
just playing up the idea that his former
squad mates are coming to kill him so
everybody that he's known before his
people from before Afghanistan are
coming to kill him now so he can't trust
anybody which is why he's so paranoid
and why he gets involved with micro so
that's why you've seen them cut all the
teasers and the trailers like this so
far like someone's listening into a
transmission and someone's watching a
body cam from one of the other soldiers
so this is like micro hacking these
soldiers body cams and that's how we're
watching Punisher do all this so that's
probably how he finds out about him and
tries to reach out to him so I'm
guessing that micro contacts Frank
before Frank finds out about micro but
the actual synopsis for the series they
just release reads after exacting
revenge on those responsible for the
death of his wife and children Frank
Castle Jon Bernthal uncovers a
conspiracy that runs far deeper than New
York's criminal underworld now known
through the city as The Punisher
he must discover the truth about in
justices that affect more than his
family alone so that's where you get
into Rollins that's where you get into
jigsaw with his anvil corporation so
it'll be awesome and they also drop some
more surveillance teaser type footage
it's of the two homeland security agents
talking about what happened during
daredevil season two about how Frank
Castle the Punishers they refer to him
takes down his former military commander
but they believe him to be dead now I
want you to get me whatever we have on a
Marine Force Recon colonel called
Schoonover the explosion and drug bust
at the 41st Street docks last year and
everything available on one of his men
lieutenant Frank
Cassidy the Punisher he's dead so it
sounds like what happened is is in this
moment here at the end of season two he
fakes his death in this big explosion
and goes underground so don't be
surprised if you're a little bit
confused about that they'll address it
in the first episode like those tell you
what Frank has been doing while
defenders has been happening and don't
worry if you were bummed out that he
didn't show up during defenders it was
because they were doing all this crazy
magical stuff now that we've gotten past
that now that they've shelved the hand
they can do more real world stuff I
think the defenders season 2 villain is
going to be the kingpin so that's where
Punisher comes back
it just fits a little bit better with
the way they're treating the Punisher
character like he's not gonna be doing
too many magical things although we can
always hope for a ghostwriter crossover
because he's still floating around ABC
right now but for those of you asking
about Ghost Rider Netflix series I'm
sure they're talking about a little bit
but there hasn't been any movement about
that I think they're just trying to get
the Punisher off the ground and deal
with what's happening with the next
seasons of all the other regular shows
then they might start talking about
other characters to introduce but yeah
for sure 100 percent believe that they
will introduce other new characters that
can get spin-offs just like the Punisher
god so people that want moon night
people that want Ghost Rider is long as
Netflix Disney and Marvel get along
they'll continue to do stuff like that
but what'll happen next this is I'll
post my Rick and Morty trailer video for
the next episode then I have new Game of
Thrones to post so hopefully there'll be
three videos today there's probably
gonna be some new flash season 4 footage
that'll drop too so I'll just give a
video schedule update when I post that
Rick and Morty video you know just leave
the ticki giveaway open in this video
till I post new marble so while you wait
for everything click here for all my
other punisher videos and you can click
here for brand new rick and morty thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you